[Music]
Haru Nakajima is arguably the most
famous Japanese actor of all time but
you've probably never seen his face
that's because Nakajima was inside the
body of a giant monster that destroyed
Tokyo why should I show that was it all
yes not yeah I don't know this
[Music]
shortly after the end of World War two
harue Nakajima went to work for the
movie studio Touhou pictures in Tokyo
Japan to pursue his dream of becoming an
actor he got his start as a stuntman and
samurais films such as Seven Samurai
which were all the rage at the time
Schulman a fellow multi-class like
should joke here there's a lot clearer
but it was on the set of a world war ii
film eagle of the Pacific where Nakajima
copy I of the director Ichiro Honda
Alohomora Jenna communities are you okay
sorry I'm alone
Cornelia Mohandas and I said Ganga is
after you and I say yuki-onna en de nada
is Sonia what the Bajau she was hosting
an ekala Nakajima met with Honda and the
production team for this new untitled
monster movie but no one really had any
direction for his role as the monster so
he started doing research hey homie
today yo yo nunca la cara doce de
courten Kojima's are all here whole
ayatö days old wha what is a holiday on
top of that creating the creature suit
was no easy task especially in post-war
Japan gorillas Rosaura like la la want
available knock there even a little
study nourished cocoon right almost not
hormonal yet that's easily lighting that
this hottie Tottie's
staining us in action alcohol is a very
optimistic
[Music]
after six grueling months of shooting
the first Godzilla movie was released in
Japan in 1954 no one had any idea how it
would be received at all a is Tammy Dunn
each melon only shows a hold of me night
cover discreet 10-meter contact the
holidays beneath my shaco spell from the
biggest shutter yeah this cups an animal
claw Godzilla wound up becoming one of
Japan's most ubiquitous cultural
milestone both for its achievements in
filmmaking and its message of the
dangers of atomic weapon and Nakajima
keep it on the monster suit for 11 more
movies and at 87 years old it is the
pride of his life no sign of the end of
Oklahoma Little Italy and I look too
much con man chillin in the Octagon man
before the title
you